This is Opportunity Scout. It decides
whether a job or a research programme
is worth applying to, and refuses to
write the application when it is not.
I built it because I measured the
workflow it replaced, and that workflow
was slower than doing the job by hand.
What it saved was not time. It was
two applications out of five that I
should never have started.
Three pieces. The agent loop is one
file. The tools live in a separate
process, an M C P server, zero
dependencies. And a model.
The tools are: fetch a posting, check
a G P A gate, log the run. That is all
of them.
The design decision I want to point out
is that this is a loop, not a chain.
In the version before this I carried
text between five fixed prompts by
hand. I decided what happened next.
Here the model decides which tool to
call and when to stop.
So the number of steps is not knowable
before it runs, and that is the
actual line between a
workflow and an agent.
One thing first. This dashboard imports
the same function the command line
calls, so every line you see appear is
the agent emitting an event live, not
a replay.
S P A R is a real research fellowship
with applications open. Watch which
tools it calls.
It fetched the posting. Now it has a
check G P A gate tool available, and it
is not calling it, because S P
A R states no G P A requirement.
A tool that runs with no reason to
run is a defect, not a bonus. That
restraint is one of the
six things I test for.
Verdict: apply. And the history table
on the right picks it up, because that
is a file on disk, not a variable.
Same agent, different posting. K A U
S T states a minimum G P A of three
point five out of four.
There. It called the G P A gate on its
own. I never told it to. It read the
threshold off the posting and
decided the check was necessary.
Now look at what came back. Pass or
fail, and the threshold tested. Not my G
P A.
The number lives in a git-ignored
file the model never sees. The tool
answers the question without
the answer leaving my machine.
Verdict: skip. And notice there is
no email. When the answer is skip it
produces nothing to send, because a
polished email for an application I
cannot make is worse
than no output at all.
Here are the real numbers. Six eval
cases written before the agent existed.
Nine out of nine on the mechanical
assertions, but only nine out of fourteen
on judgement.
E four and E five are the weak ones.
It does not reliably say no evidence
for a skill I do not have. That is
a prompt problem I have not solved.
And the limitation I most want to show
you is this. When I ran these evals,
E two, the G P A case, failed.
Not because the model was wrong.
Because I had cut the posting fetch from
six thousand characters to two and
a half thousand to stay under a rate
limit, and K A U S T states
its minimum past that cut.
So the agent never saw the requirement,
reasoned correctly that there was
not one, and told me to apply to
a programme I cannot get into.
A performance optimisation had silently
become a correctness failure, in the
exact behaviour that justifies the
agent existing. An eval I wrote before
any of the code caught it.
One last thing. This agent cannot
send anything. No email tool, no form
filling. Not disabled, absent.
Sending is the only irreversible action
here, so the guardrail is that the
capability does not exist.